this is Joel Gaz de chef and
restauranteur he came in a bright blue
suit that no one should ever wear could
we cut your hair fairly dramatically so
could we shave your facial hair again he
had some tricky facial hair going on and
I think he was living in a different
decade you look like you're in Boogie
Nights you're in my favorite decade
you're in the 70s here staying alive
kept playing over and over in my mind
you know staying alive staying alive is
a very the BG's and then for a minute of
his dirk diggler and I thought we were
in the San Fernando Valley shooting a
porn film in 1979 and Julianne Moore was
going to come in a minute and so was
somebody on rollerskates my style before
the makeover was quite eclectic very
crazy a mix of things um let's take a
picture of your step against the wall if
you could
well talk about a dramatic makeover so I
think it was great because we were able
to look at him with a fresh eye and just
say wow this guy's great-looking he has
amazing hair I mean I don't know what
that was it was kind of a modern mullet
I think it was a 70s sort of David
Cassidy thing that turned into a mullet
given his stature and the size of your
head haha a smaller necktie will make
your neck look longer and make
everything look slim whooping a million
bucks welcome to the world of fashion
this is my models have traumas okay
great
he felt he had a certain swagger and
obviously he had stayed with that for
many many years but when he saw himself
clean-shaven with that haircut that
orbit gave him it was just a really a
reality check and suddenly it's like I
don't why just owned one restaurant I
can own a chain of them chin gown look
into the camera lens chin down again
I've got to appreciate myself and the
image I present to the world more the
attention to detail on the inside and
the outside it's important I mean this
is a guy who owns a restaurant leave a
restaurant entrepreneur in the making
and part of what we want to do we asked
all the guys where do you want to be in
five years where do you want to be in
ten years and help them dress their
future you know dress the part and it
will come to you so dressed like a
restaurant entrepreneur you will be a
restaurant entrepreneur you will own
many restaurants so you need to dress
like what you want to be in life